"Almost two years ago, we announced that DeKalb Medical would be seeking a partner for the future,
and then almost a year ago we selected Emory Healthcare as that partner."
Emery Healthcare leadership and community dignitaries
were recently on hand to celebrate the partnership between DeKalb Medical and Emory Healthcare.
"We are now stronger than we have ever been as we move into this partnership with Emory."
"The partnership will bring together two organizations that really have community care at their center,
and by combining the resources of the two organizations,
we're going to be able to provide services in communities that haven't had those services.
We're also going to be able to take care of our community in ways that we haven't even imagined in the past."
In addition to DeKalb Medical on North Decatur Road becoming Emory Decatur Hospital,
DeKalb Medical Hillandale is now Emory Hillandale Hospital and DeKalb Medical Long-term Acute Care
Downtown Decatur is now called Emory Long-term Acute Care.
"So today signifies an important turning point for both of our organizations,
and I count myself extremely fortunate to be part of this inspiring and transformational event."
"Really the big winner is the community. It's the communities served by both the DeKalb Medical
hospitals, physicians, as well as the communities served by Emory Healthcare."
"I'm hearing excellent things --- the patients here in DeKalb and the community are more excited than we are as
employees because they feel like they're going to have first-class service throughout DeKalb County."
"It's not about getting bigger simply for the sake of being bigger. It's really about having that
relevant size that allows you to better meet the needs of your population.
We're incredibly excited to welcome the DeKalb family to the broader Emory Healthcare, making us almost 25,000 people strong,
three additional acute care facilities and really the ability to better meet the needs of the community and all their healthcare needs.